In this lesson, we're going to go and take a look at screen space and global illumination.
So let's get started.
So screen space global illumination can be activated within our project settings and
also within the Puzz process volume.
Let me point out where those are at and then we're going to look at a few things we can
do to actually do a little quality control and things to look out for, especially if
you're using it for ICVFX.
So in my scene here, what I want to do is first go into my project settings.
Again, you can activate this after the fact if you want to, but in your project settings,
if your intentions are to use it, it's good to actually have it on anyway.
So we would go underneath and take a look at our settings here.
You'll see under reflection method, we have screen space global illumination active.
We have overall we have ray tracing in here.
And that's because if we want to use GPU, if we want to use GPU light mask, we actually
want to turn this on and make sure that it is on.
If you don't have this on, it won't work.
So it's using ray tracing in this particular case, but we can also use screen space.
If we wanted to for our GI, you just have to be careful if you decide to do that, even
in your overrides, you have to keep those things in mind.
Screen space will give you a bit of a clipping that could occur if you're using it for ICVFX.
So you've got to be aware of that because when you move your camera, you can see glowing
objects and certain materials start to clip away and you'll have to do a bit of an over scan.
Let's talk about that.
So it's not necessarily the norm to use this type of effect.
And again, you can see the two areas where we can turn it on.
If you decide to use it in your scene and maybe you're not using GPU light mask and you're
using regular CPU bake, you again want to change that in your global illumination settings.
And they can also be done in your post process volume.
But just keep in mind, if your scene isn't very big, that might be okay.
But if it's a large scene, it takes a while to bake for updates needed by the director.
That might be a little bit of a problem.
So if you do decide to use it though, in that context, you want to go into your, your NDC
in your NDC, you want to go to your viewport over scan.
And in here, you want to make sure that you're making it just a little bit bigger than your
area of interest.
And this is going to be very important because as you move your camera around, like I said
before, your, if you don't do this, you can actually get clipping on the edges of your
camera.
So you want to make sure you over scan that just a bit so that that clipping does not occur
at the edge of your camera.
If we go to Unreal, we can see here a viewport over scan option here.
And we also have viewport screen percentages.
So we can actually change these as we need.
There's the main wall.
So we can enable this if we need to over scan and choose how much we want to shift things.
Same thing with the sidewall and same thing with the wild wall.
This is up to you how you do so.
Just keep this in mind that it is a good idea to over scan if you are going to use this
method.
Rating space also has several quality settings that you can enable using the following commands.
In using your console variable, you can use r.ssgi for quality and using number between
one and four to control that quality.
You'll see the number chart that I placed in the lecture here.
It says one is ray steps eight, ray count four, two, ray steps eight, ray count eight,
three, ray steps eight, ray count 16, and four here, ray steps 12, and ray count 32.
So the resolution command to render at half resolution is dart.ssgi for half res.
To use previous frames seeing color to achieve better quality results, you can use r.ssgi
for minimum illuminance.
So these are things that you can use.
Remember these number counts between one and four for quality control here is at the top,
but these ray counts you do need to keep in mind exactly what it is you're going for,
what your visuals are going to be, and if you're going to over scan overall.
Now again, using screens, physical illumination isn't the typical norm.
Typically you would use Lumen and just adjust your materials and build your scene accordingly.
This is an option for possibly maybe lower end machines or you're maybe running to situations
where the noise is a bit too much.
You may then want to switch to this and it's actually a pretty cheap way to use things.
And let me show you a few things to keep in mind if you decide to use it.
So in this case, we'll just pretend ours is on.
Right now we're currently using ray tracing for our GI and I'm in the secondary post
process volume reference.
If you are looking this and downloading this for the class,
I'm just using this particular lot one that's already been loaded.
So in here, you'll see that we can actually go to our advanced settings and when we have it on.
And let's see if we can just go ahead and pop this on real quick.
We want to Lumen, we're going to do a screen space in this case.
Let's see things shift a little bit.
You can correct your indirect lighting color and your indirect lighting intensity.
So these things can be controlled.
You see a little bit of a popping going on here.
And you also see a little bit of a color shift if I choose to.
Now this is contained within our post process volume, but this is up to you and it may conflict
a bit with our light.
But you have that option to be able to control this on a very low level.
And you'll see a little bit of brightness going on if you were to use it.
And these overrides work pretty well.
I'm going to set that to none.
I'm going to put that as method, turn that off in general and turn these off too.
But the advanced area is where you're going to get the ability to be able to control the
brightness of that if you decided to go in this direction.
Typically when you use SSGI, you want to make sure that you're using it in such a way so
that it's complimentary to previously baked items that you have in your scene.
That's typically what it's used with.
Does that mean you can't use it with ray tracing?
Well, you actually can.
And for some reason you're using ray tracing and you're noticing it's very slowing.
It's slowing down greatly.
Your brute force seems to be bringing things to a crawl.
Maybe you're not on stage.
Maybe it's just simply for virtual production or final pixel.
You can switch into your global illumination to be screen space in general.
And that would actually make things go a little bit smoother.
Just keep in mind the difference between those because you can keep ray trace reflections on
and use screen space in that particular scenario.
Again, you want to be able to block this out.
You want to make sure things are exactly the way that you want ahead of time.
So just be very deterministic, but typically it's used as a complementary tool
for your baking scenarios.
That's it with this lecture.
Here's a link here for you to dive in deeper on these particular topics.
Thanks again.
And in the next video, we're going to go and take a look at ICVFX
when it comes to ray tracing as a bit of a review.